Speaker 1: We have a voicemail number.
That number is two one nine two. David,
P.. This is so funny. We have this viewer,
Jen from Providence, and she's called in
a bunch of times during live shows. She
is going to be. She has a Jewish friend.
And Jen wants to know, How am I supposed to deal
with a Jewish friend on Christmas? Listen to this.
Speaker 5: Hi, David. Jen from Providence. I
actually have a nonpolitical question for you.
Hmm. Oh, my best friend is Jewish. Offer a name,
David, and we've invited him over for Christmas.
All right. Do we get him a Christmas present?
Speaker 1: All the confused and
bewildered tone. I just love Oh,
Speaker 5: how do we go about this or are
there certain things that we should avoid?
Speaker 1: I would avoid blaming him for
the death of Jesus. Maybe. I think that
would be something appropriate to avoid.
Speaker 5: I he's the first Jewish person I've
actually really personally known. I grew up in
the south where they weren't really there. I
think I know this just kind of weird. It's more
of a Dear Abby thing. Oh man,
Speaker 1: I. OK, so listen,
here's the deal. Jewish person is invited over
for Christmas. If you're getting everybody gifts,
maybe you get him a gift. It's not a
big deal. It's really not, you know,
you don't have to do anything special. Just don't,
either. There's something so endearing about like,
Listen, I don't want, I don't want to do this.
Should I avoid certain things? I don't know. Maybe
you don't. If you're saying some kind of Christian
Grace before the meal, maybe you don't go to the
Jewish friend. I'm not even really sure, but
I'm sure, Jen, that it's going to go great.
And also, by the way, a funny thing when people
say this is really the only Jewish person I know
or something. I've never met a Jewish person
before. Almost always. If you're an adult in the
United States, even if you're from the South, what
you mean is I wasn't aware of the Jewish people
that I met because it's not necessarily announced
or obvious. Um, and I guess it's theoretically
possible that you could get through much of life
without ever meeting a Jewish person. But for
the most part, it's you didn't know the person
was Jewish. It's sort of like, you know what?
Someone says, I don't even know, Oh, you know, I'm
colorblind, really. I've never met anyone who's
colorblind. Colorblindness is common enough that
you probably did meet someone who's colorblind,
but it just wasn't made a topic of conversation. I
don't know if that's a suitable analogy, but Jen,
I think you're going to do great. I really do. I
think please report back and tell us how it goes.
We have a great bonus show for you today. There is
major controversy building about Kyle Rittenhouse
and Arizona State University. And this started
during the trial, and it has now blown up into
something much different and much bigger. We're
going to talk about it on today's bonus show.
We will also talk about a federal appeals court
upholding the California ban on high capacity
firearm magazines and what it means and whether
it's likely to remain. And lastly, we are going
to talk about the ex officer who killed Daunte
Wright. This is the trial of Kim Potter. This is
another trial that is now going on. We're going
to talk about it, and it's not one we've talked
about as much. So we will discuss that on the
bonus show. So number one, if you want to listen
to today's bonus show, watch the bonus show.
Become a member at join Pacman dot com. Every
weekday we do another show for our members at
Join Pacman dot com. You can use the coupon
code Felony 21 to get a huge discount. It's
such a large discount it should be a felony,
but it's not. It's just a discount, OK? Sign up at
join Pacman dot com! Additionally, December 14th,
now less than two weeks away, we will be doing our
next David Pakman Show Viewer Town Hall. It'll be
at 6:00 p.m. Eastern streaming live on our second
YouTube channel. That's Pacman Live. If you want
to watch, you're welcome to watch. If you want to
call in, you're welcome to call in as well. It's
wide open. If you want priority during the call
ins, get a membership at Join Pacman dot com. We
will see you on the bonus show and also back
Unidentified: on tomorrow's program.